YUFENG GUO: Google Cloud's
AI Platform Training now
has built-in
algorithms that you can
use to train models without
writing a single line of code.
Let's dive in and find
out how you can use it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MECHANICAL SOUNDS]
[SWOOSH]
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode, we're
going to use AI Platform's
built-in algorithms
to train and deploy
a machine-learning model without
writing any training code.
The tool acts as a handy wrapper
around AI Platform Training,
and it bridges the gap between
AutoML and full custom training
jobs.
Now, as of this recording,
this feature is still in beta.
But perhaps if you're
watching this in the future,
it may already be
generally available.
Now, before we can
really get going on this,
we want to decide
what it is we're
going to build a model for.
In this case, I've got
here the US Census data
set, a classic
binary classification
machine-learning problem.
This means that the goal will be
to separate this data into one
of two groups.
In this case, our data comes
from the 1994 US Census.
And the task will be to
predict if a given household
income will be above or
below $50,000 a year.
With this context
in place, let's look
at how we can use AI Platform
Training to train up this model
without writing any code.
To get started with AI
Platform Training using
built-in algorithms,
head on over
to the Jobs menu in
the Cloud console
and click on New Training Job.
In that menu, you
will see two options.
Click on Built-in
Algorithm Training.
The first step is to
select our algorithm.
Currently, there are a
handful of options mostly
around structured data, though,
there are a few about images
as well which we
won't cover today.
The three structured
data algorithms
that are currently available
are XGBoost, a Linear Learner,
and the Wide and Deep Learner.
As the names suggest, XGBoost
uses the popular implementation
of gradient-boosted trees, while
the Linear Learner essentially
models something like
linear regression.
And finally, the
Wide and Deep Learner
uses the TensorFlow
research model
Wide and Deep which tries
to combine the memorization
benefits of a wide linear model
with the strong generalization
capabilities of deep
neural networks.
Once you've selected
an algorithm,
we need to specify
the training data.
This system takes as input the
Google Cloud Storage URL path.
So your data will need to be
uploaded onto Google Cloud
Storage beforehand.
And additionally,
for structured data,
this system is expecting
specifically a headerless CSV
file.
And furthermore, the
prediction target column
must be the very first
column of that CSV file.
So it may mean
that you need to do
a bit of light
preprocessing just
to move things around a bit.
And if your CSV
file is small enough
to load into a spreadsheet
software of your choice,
I would recommend
just using that
and dragging your label column
over into that first column
position.
Then just delete that
header row, if there is one,
and export the
file as a CSV file.
This is probably the
most straightforward way
to generate that
appropriate output format.
The system allows you to specify
a validation data and test
data, either as separate
files or as a percentage
of the training data.
So if your data is mixed in all
together, using the percentages
is an easy and convenient
way to ensure that you
have representative metrics.
If you have separate files for
Training, Validation, and Test,
make sure that all
three are representative
of the same reality.
Otherwise, your training
results, oh, they
might surprise you.
So once you've specified all
the different training data,
the next screen is all about
specifying the algorithm
arguments.
This menu will differ depending
on which algorithm you choose.
Each one has a somewhat
long list of parameters
that you can specify.
Now, while many default
values are provided,
there is also extensive
documentation for each value
that you can set.
Additionally, a lot
of these parameters
are available to be
used for HyperTune,
which is Google Cloud Platform's
hyperparameter tuning service.
To use it, check
the HyperTune box,
and provide a lower and upper
bound for the hyperparameter
that you want to have
the system tune for you.
Be sure to check off Allow early
stopping of HyperTune trials.
This will allow you
to take advantage
of early stopping of any
unpromising trials, which
will save compute and time.
Once your algorithm arguments
are set, click Next,
and we just have a
few final details
to provide about
the training job.
Give it a job ID, region,
and select the scale tier,
and then the training
will commence.
While the model is training,
you can make a coffee,
maybe read some web comics,
or kick off another training
job in parallel.
Since it's pretty lightweight
to start a training job,
you can try different models
and different parameter ranges
pretty easily.
Once training is
complete, you can
click on the job to view
some of the details,
including resource
utilization as well as links
to Stackdriver Logging.
You can also deploy your model
directly from that screen.
There's a Deploy Model
button at the top, which
will grab the exported
model from Google Cloud
Storage for you and
deploy it out so you
can have a REST API to call
your models for predictions.
So there you have
it, an easy way
to run model training
and deployment
without needing to write
a single line of code
while still having
the controls that you
want for adjusting the
details of a particular model.
This can save time
while still enabling
you to get high-quality results
customized for your use case
and data set.
For more details and
examples, check out the links
included in the
description below.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed it,
click that Like button,
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out
AI Platform Training
using built-in algorithms,
and see what kind of results
you can produce.
[MUSIC PLAYING]